welcome to
the free webinar on introduction to ngs
for
gene expression studies in
today's session we will discuss about
the
upcoming omics logic transcriptomics
program that will be focused
on analytical approaches for rna-seq
data to study
gene and isoform expression in various
organisms
across many conditions
so let me first introduce you to the
omics logic programs
omits logic programs are a result of
close collaboration between pi biotech
and innovative big data analytics
company based in the u.s
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design
as a result the omics logic programs
have been thoroughly
tested around the world and are known to
lead
to excellent outcomes for students with
minimal bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics
data science and biomedical research
i am honored to have been working with a
team
that collectively has amazing experience
in this area including the other
co-founders of the company
dr alfred tober who comes from a medical
background with
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry
of inflammation has a long-standing
recognition for his generous support
of many international projects and
research activities
one of these projects is the
establishment of the october
matrix research center which has been at
the core
of what we do dr leonid brodsky is the
director of the tower bioinformatics
research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications on
bioinformatics and over the course of
his career
has developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research
in biotechnology pharmaceutical research
and development
agriculture and basic research there are
also
other team members comprising of
bioinformaticians computer scientists
and biologists
who have contributed to the creation of
these courses
programs and resources we will use and
refer to
in today's session and our upcoming
programs
now let me introduce you to the
experts and bioinformaticians who will
mentor
sessions and guide you through the
program
we have dr harpreet kaur she is our
omits logic trainer and expert
bioinformatician who mentors sessions
and guides participants
her area of pa specialization is cancer
genomics
dr mohit mazumdar has a phd in
computational biology and over 10 years
of experience
working with industry and academia
he is also a project mentor elia brodsky
is our ceo
and co-founder his experience in
research in academia has led to many
research labs and university
collaborations
and has been recognized for the
simplified approach to omits
analysis for education
our omits logic programs are attended by
participants from all over the world so
as you can see we have participants from
india united states nigeria egypt united
kingdom
and many more countries so i would want
to
pause here and ask all of you where are
you joining us
today where are you all from today so
you can write down the names of your
countries or where are you joining us
from
and also okay thank you so much jose for
sharing this
great this is great to see so we have
participants right now from
india and egypt also from mexico
so that is great to see and
if you all can also tell us about what
is your current
educational level are you a phd
are you an undergraduate student if you
are a researcher or a faculty
please post that down in the chat thank
you so much uh somdaria for sharing
and also everyone else
okay great that is great to meet
everyone so moving on
my name is beepsha biswas
and i am the omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users who are part of our
growing biofue matrix community
so as you see here we have a lot of
participants who join us from
everywhere in the world and even in
today's session as you see that all of
you are coming from different places
so this is a great opportunity to not
only
learn from a session but also interact
with each other and learn from
each other
and now moving on i wanted to introduce
you to the omics logic program
the omixlogic transcriptomics program uh
we have
organized this uh twice before this year
so this is going to be the third time
that we will be doing this program
and we had many participants who were
able to successfully complete the
program
and they were undergraduate students
graduate students faculty and phds
and the feedback which was shared by our
previous participants and their progress
is very encouraging to our team as well
as to the participants who will continue
to take these courses
and the main thing is the experience in
designing biofuel matrix projects with
the help of
mentor support which is an important
aspect of our omics logic programs which
has helped
many of our previous participants
as you see here ulja was a participant
in our research fellowship
program and she completed a project on
differential identification of
biomarkers between neural stem cells and
glioblastoma stem cells
and then she went on to win an award
for doing this project which was a in a
word in a student research congress and
like urja there are other participants
who had
participated in different team
challenges
one different awards and continued to do
this
so these are all these uh photos or
screenshots that you can see that
you will be able to see even in our
linkedin channel from different
participants who share this
and now i would want to invite delia
brodsky to speak more about today's
session and
introduce you to ngs for gene expression
studies
so over to you elia
thank you pizza
okay so welcome everyone to this webinar
for those of you that don't know me
my name is elia broadsky i'm the
co-founder and ceo of pine biotech
what our company does is that we really
have
a vision to enhance human health and
well-being
by enabling biological research and
discovery
providing relevant data solutions and
support
our mission here at pine biotech is to
simplify bioinformatics make it
more accessible helping different types
of users
participate in advanced research one
way that we are doing this is through
our modular and intuitive multi-omics
analysis platform that we will talk
about
today but importantly
we appreciate the role that training
research support
and big data analytics tools that are
designed
for different types of researchers and
different areas in biomedical discovery
so our mission is really to support
cutting edge research and to solve
the big data challenges we want to make
sure that our solutions are easy to use
and we we engage in these training
programs
so that those that are interested to use
big data
analysis tools can use them effectively
and arrive at sound and reproducible
results
so while we focus on research support
and develop
tools for research we also do a lot of
training and this program
is an important program because we see
many biologists struggling
with the types of data and the types of
insights that these data
can provide that are driving research
ideas
and helping them develop more
competitive and more compelling
research projects so what this program
in transcriptomics will do is
introduce rna-seq processing so you
really understand what the data
represents and where it comes from it
will also allow you to try
different tools that prepare the data
for analysis
explain some of the statistical
principles in
analysis of transformative data whether
it is
a simple experiment with just a couple
of conditions that could be compared or
there's a more complex experiment design
but also importantly introduce you to
machine learning tools that are commonly
used for analysis of big data sets as
you know these big data sets have been
increasing in their complexity and so
to illustrate how some of these methods
are used
we're going to take a project driven
approach
that explains exactly how these
different aspects fit together
into the analysis process so as you know
next generation sequencing is now a
technology that is well accepted and has
become
very affordable and accessible providing
huge consortia that give us thousand
access to thousands of samples on any
given
type of a phenotype and so we'll talk
about how
phenotypic data that could be
illustrated by cell morphology
or tissue type could be further explored
at the genetic level where we see
genetic variation at the dna level
different aspects of epigenomic
regulation
and then transcriptonics what this data
provides us with
is an ability to infer the
relationship between what is encoded in
the dna
and what we see produced at the protein
level
so at that level it is very interesting
to observe
kind of a snapshot a molecular detailed
snapshot of what's going on
inside tissues cells and individual
organisms so what we'll do in this
program is we'll talk about
how as a method of measuring rna
translation transcriptonic studies
can help detect mrna expression inside
the cell
as an accurate alternative to membrane
protein expression detection
which allows for molecular precision in
diagnostics
and new insights for the development of
treatments based on molecular pathways
so rna-seq as a methodology has
revolutionized the way that biologists
examine transcriptones
and has been successfully applied in
many areas of
basic biological research drug discovery
and also clinical diagnostics and
treatment selection
compared with other technologies like
microarray based transcriptome profiling
pcr quantification rna-seq has
a much wider dynamic range which means
that it can detect
many uh variations of the same
transcript alternative splicing
avoids a lot of the technical
limitations such as varying probe
performance
and cross hybridization and rnac can
measure the expression levels of
thousands
genes of genes simultaneously and
provide insights into functional
pathways
and the regulatory networks and
biological systems
importantly rnac can provide novel
insights into alternative splicing
detect unannotated exons and novel
transcripts
most importantly such detail has already
provided proven to yield significant
discoveries
in many research areas so what this
program will focus on
is to explain how bioinformatics is
an important component of such studies
and is designed around integration of
multiple types of data
transcriptonics being the primary focus
but nevertheless looking at the wider
picture
of how we can understand complex
conditions
such as diseases at the subcellular
level
and identify important players in this
network
of associated features how
analysis of these interactions can help
us identify
novel patterns insights biomarkers
and targets for drug design and
repurposing
so though biomedical projects that we
will use will show how
such aspects of diagnostics could be
applied to cancer biology
how we can classify different diseases
and stratify patients understanding
different
groups and associations between
biomarker features
and patient outcomes and we'll also look
at single cell
and tissue composition so the program
is really designed to give you a high
level overview of bioinformatics
specifically focus on transcriptomic
data analysis
and then introduce you to some resources
like projects
training materials and tools that will
help you make the most
of rna-seq data so let me briefly
explain how these different topics are
going to be covered
in the upcoming program we will start
with
an overview of tools and resources
we will then go to speak about how to
process next generation sequencing data
that comes out of the sequencer
and we'll talk about what are
bioinformatics pipelines and what are
some of the
design strategies for these pipelines to
make
them produce insights that we can later
on
analyze using downstream analysis tools
then we'll talk about preparing the data
for in-depth analysis it's important to
understand normalization
how the data is distributed what are
some of the technical variations that we
should eliminate
before we try to compare different
conditions
and try to infer biological meaning
we'll then talk
also about a new i think
paradigm in such data when we're going
from just
a couple of samples per condition to
really
tens or even hundreds of samples that
allow us to train machine learning
models
and design predictive analysis to really
understand
association between clinical and
phenotypic classes and specific
molecular features that we have in our
data
we'll then talk about another emerging
technology which is single cell rna-seq
data and
there we'll look at tissue specific
expression based on analysis of
thousands and even millions of cells at
a time where we can analyze
specific variation and compare that
variation
by tissue cell type and association with
different phenotypes the ultimate goal
of this program
is to help you design a project of your
own
and so we will provide you with several
examples but we will also
allow you to try to find and design
a project of your own and to support an
in-depth research project we will also
introduce you to a variety of tools
but importantly we will guide how that
process happens from the start of
selecting your data
to then designing your analysis and then
finally working through
all of the technical issues that are
associated with that
and to help you make the most of that we
have
a number of mentors that will be helping
to go through that process with you
and some of those will be speaking today
as well
now the process of this uh whole program
is designed around a schedule that you
can see here on the screen
starting from december 8th we will meet
uh
two or three times a week for three
weeks but the whole program is designed
around
a month and during this month what we've
seen in the past
is you would be surprised how much
progress you can make as somebody who is
completely new to bioinformatics
or as somebody that knows about some of
the technical aspects of bioinformatics
but has never really applied them to
your own research project so that's
really
the objective of this program now this
program consists of several
elements that are built to work together
to help you make the most
out of the program and that includes
interactive sessions
where we meet in a group setting
go over the material answer questions
and try some practical assignments
together
but in between sessions you will have
access to self-guided study materials
and those materials are designed
to break down the complex topics that
require some
in-depth review review additional
research materials that will help you
understand the problems that we are
solving
and also some practical assignments that
are going to be done
both using a an intuitive platform that
i'll show in just a moment
as well as some practical assignments
encoding that opt
that are optional but will help you
understand what goes into producing
different types of data structures
visualization of those data structures
different types of analysis techniques
and biological interpretation
so the online course work is designed to
help you study independently and will
help you prepare for the different
interactive sessions to make the most of
them
during those asynchronous materials you
will be able to watch videos review the
text and really understand the details
behind some of the things that we are
speaking
now in these courses you will find
important information that will help you
keep track of important words
understanding
some of the research reasoning behind
what we are discussing
and really understand how all of this
fits together so it's a very
methodological process of going through
the material
that if you already know you will be
able to
kind of skip over now you will be able
to download all of these materials as
pdfs and make sure that you understand
all of these um and and can have them
for later as well
so as i mentioned there are also
practical assignments and this is an
important part of bioinformatics that
we don't only speak about how
bioinformatics is applied but we
actually try to do it ourselves
and so here you will find specific types
of reviewed
assignments that you submit and get
feedback on
and also get to try some of the tools
both as a interactive platform that i
will show in just a second
uh but also uh you will see how the
platform helps you
in helps introduce you to the details of
the methods that we will discuss
so let me show you briefly what that
really will look like
uh for those of you that want to follow
along
you can go to
dot server.tbio.info so i'll just put
the link here in
the chat
thank you beeps so let's go over
to this uh platform just so that you
have a really
clear sense of what we are going to be
doing
so this is the t-biome for platform you
can see server.tbio.info
the platform allows processing analysis
and visualization of
multiple types of omix data so that's
why we are talking about
a multi-omics integration logic in
a lot of our programs this logic is
circled around processing tools and then
downstream analysis tools that i'll talk
about in a second
so for transcriptomics we will explore
how you can analyze specific types of
output data from a sequencer which come
in a format
that contains short sequences of reads
then those reads are processed to
eliminate technical variation
and after those are trimmed out and
pre-processed you can proceed to go on
to
mapping to the reference genome now that
could be done
using several different strategies it
could be a detailed view
of alternative alternative splicing
events
it could be a mapping on the
transcriptome
or it could be what's called a joint
strategy so
strategy that combines both mapping onto
the whole genome
preparing a novel transcriptome and then
mapping on to that transcript
now these are different strategies that
are important to understand because they
play a role
in our ability to ask specific questions
of the data
and have accurate information for us to
be able to validate our assumptions
based on what we find in the original
data that came out of the sequence
so we'll talk about some of these
pipelines we'll also talk about
some of the variation of the pipelines
and some of the downstream analysis
where you will find
such popular packages as dc and
others so importantly in this process
you will be able to understand the logic
behind
what we did understand how each one of
the methods
is uh addressing a practical challenge
and then see the results in for yourself
in the context of a project
right so really understanding the
biological clinical
and research significance of a project
data set
so as you go through this process you
will find that
some of the methods provide very
standard outputs
and those outputs have to be expanded on
so you might want to modify the way that
you visualize maybe
change some of the settings so you
really need more flexibility
and to provide you with an insight on
how to address some of those questions
we have designed some practical uh
assignments that you will see as we go
through the program
using coding exercises
in these coding exercises you will get
an introduction
to methods of using
python and r bio python
and different packages in r
to really go through some of the
downstream analysis
uh be able to load your data and
visualize your results
so just to again illustrate what those
will look like
i'm just going to show you a quick
example in r
so in this program we will for example
focus on
differential gene expression and so
after you've learned about differential
gene expression
you will get a breakdown of how the data
is loaded in and prepared for analysis
after you've gone through that you will
be able to
run your analysis right here
in the browser and so what's important
here is that we will go through some
examples that have variations
at the level of uh the input data
that you see right here but running this
in the browser provides you with
a problem-free and
bug-free environment where you can get
your results and we can all do this
in the context of a single session so
you don't only get to
learn about the code you also get to run
it and we get to compare results
at the end so as we talk about this
program
as i mentioned the tools are a critical
important part of this program and they
are not designed for just people that
know how to code or for
bioinformaticians
they're designed for biologists and
clinicians so anybody can
learn from this experience after you've
learned how to prepare the pipelines and
you understand
each individual method you'll be able to
produce outputs
that explain what the data shows
from a biological perspective so we'll
go through stages
of statistical analysis but also
downstream interpretation in terms of
pathway annotation
and in terms of our ability to think of
the biological implications of the
variation that we found
but importantly we'll go through an
in-depth view because many of the
biologists don't really understand
what goes into preparing the data and
how variation in the processing
pipelines
plays an important role in your ability
to make certain
assumptions and interpretations of the
data
so we'll we'll talk about many of the
important steps of pre-processing
understanding the data being able to do
exploratory analysis
as well to help you go through that
it will not be enough to just be in the
sessions you really do
have to go through the synchronous
materials to get
all of that completed on your own and
here i want to say that also for those
that
cannot attend the interactive sessions
we are providing these materials
as a separate resource that you can get
access and do them on your own time
and i think that going through the
explanations and also doing the
practical assignments
will help you understand what goes on to
understanding your data
and then trying to work with that data
so that it makes a lot more sense
once we get to data mining and
classification i think that's where
a lot of programs skip over the basics
to go to the more interesting things and
i think that you know
big data has been playing a major role
in how research has been changing over
the past
decade and here the introduction of
machine learning tools
have transformed our ability to deal
with
the emergence of these comprehensive
data sets that allow us to really
ask complex questions and get predictive
answers about some of the some of the
conditions that we have so
in this program we'll talk about a lot
of the typical approaches
for supervised and unsupervised data
analysis uh using data mining and
classification
really understanding how the different
methods allow us to ask different types
of questions
and uh provide us with different types
of
outcomes and as i mentioned these
outcomes are going to be based on
biological
examples uh and will go from a high
level introduction
of the logic all the way into being able
to
code this kind of analysis here on your
own
starting with the code playground that i
just briefly showed
and eventually going on to try to apply
those
on your own system if you wish so really
it's a combination of a variety of tools
and resources
and hopefully many of you that join will
will find that
an intuitive experience because it
connects all of these resources together
under your own profile and at the end of
the session vipsa will
go through some of the stages of
registration and preparing your profile
so that you can make
the most out of this experience now one
of the people on our team that will be
mentoring you throughout the session is
an experienced bioinformatician she has
a phd
in bioinformatics and she will be
guiding you
through some of the materials that are a
part of this program
so i want to introduce you to dr
harpreet kaur
she is an omics logic trainer today but
she recently
did her phd with several publications
focusing on liver cancer
in her current research she continues to
apply machine learning tools and
multinomics integration tools
to really understand the biological
drivers of this disease
uh harpreet let me pass it on to you
thank you
let me share my screen
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
and i have a phd
in bioinformatics my research is on
biomarker discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
so what inspired me to study liver
cancer for my doctor research
is the high mortality rate of this
malignancy
and lack of precise biomarker that can
help diagnose liver cancer at an early
stage
worldwide liver cancer is considered as
sixth major cancer in terms of incidence
and fourth in terms of mortality
it is often a time misdiagnosed
or detected too late for an effective
treatment
another factor that contribute to
poor outcome of the liver cancer patient
is the frequent reoccurrence of the
tumor
so with these concern in mind i have
framed number of research objective
with my collaborators to address these
issues
using various bioinformatics techniques
for the first part of this research
project
we used large-scale transcriptomics data
to identify a diagnostic biomarker panel
for hepatocellular carcinoma which is
primary
labor malignancy so in this study
we employed 30 data sets containing
nearly 4 000 samples
to elucidate transcriptomics biomarker
panel
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
implementing various statistical and
bioinformatics
techniques
for the next part of this research
project we use transcriptomics
and methylation data to identify a
biomarker panel
for stage classification of
hepatocellular carcinoma
here we employ tcga data of 350 samples
and elucidate 51 features that
include 30 rna transcripts and 21
methylation
cpg sites using a number of data mining
techniques
the navy's model classified early in the
latest sample
of scc with nearly 79
accuracy
for the third part of this research
project
we use transcriptomics data to
scrutinize diagnostic biomarker panel
for chalangio carcinoma which is another
major liver malignancy
so in this study we employed nine data
sets
containing 350 colon geocarcinoma
133 addition non-tumorous
and 90 hcc samples to scrutinize
chlangiocarcinoma's specific
transcriptomic signatures
implementing a number of data mining
techniques
like extra tree svm random forest
logistic regression
lda etc so in conclusion
during this whole research project we
identified a universally
platform independent three gene based
biomarker that can predict hcc samples
with high precision and also possess
prognostic potential
then we identified a three gene based
signature that is specific to
chlangiocarcinoma
and they are capable to discriminate cca
from
hcc in the normal samples at last we
identify
a 51 features that include 30 rna
transcript
and 21 methylation cpg size
that can predict hcc at an early stage
so in my current role i am omics logic
bioinformatics trainer
with prime biotech i am assisting
participants to learn about data
analysis
machine learning and data visualization
in
application to last large datasets to
use in biomedical research
besides i am involved in designing
different research projects
using publicly available data sets
so in continuation of my liver cancer
research background
here i am working on the project
involved multi omics data integration
of liver cancer patient to find out
molecular signature
that are associated with clinical and
demographic phenotypes of the liver
cancer patients
where we not just uh use transcriptomics
data
but we have also explored mi rna and
clinical data that can be integrated in
a multi-omics
multi-omics data integration approach
here we implemented various multi-omics
data integration tools like
snf i cluster plus o2 plus
etc that are integrated on t by info
server that has already elia has shown
you
so finally we are we are trying to
understand
how multi omics data integration
analysis can provide us the holistic
picture
of this lethal pregnancy and also how
they are associated with diverse
clinical phenotypes like
tumor stage risk factors race age
and gender of the patients so
participants can explore this project
during
this program to get a better
understanding
i am looking forward to being your
mentor during this upcoming omics logic
transcriptomics program
and will help all of you learn about
data analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application
to biomedical data sets so now i would
like
pass this session back to ilia so over
to you ilya
thank you corporee um so as you can see
the ability to work with data and ask
biological questions really has to be
done in the context of projects and
another person who is going to be
guiding the participants in project
selection
and making the most out of this program
is dr mohit mizunda
so mohit i would like to ask you to
share a little bit about
how this is going to be done in this
program
sorry yeah um hello everyone and thank
you doctor
india for this wonderful overview so my
name is mohit mazumdar
and in my current role i'm working and
collaborating with universities to
introduce innovative curriculum on
data-driven biological research
at a high school undergraduate and
post-graduate levels
and developing bioinformatics research
projects
so one of the topics that we wanted to
address today
and one of the main challenges that a
research project
presents is how to get started
right so for a number of years our team
has been working on project
driven bioinformatics training programs
that are designed to help you find
develop and complete such research
projects so as
a result of this experience we have uh
we want to offer you several
suggestions to make so that you make the
most out of your
research project transcriptomics
which encompasses you know assessment of
alternate splicing
alternate poly adenylation
identification of fusion transcripts
exploration of non-coding rnas
transcendence annotation
and uh discovery of noble transcripts
right that's a lot so hence we can
surely say that
analysis of rna-seq data is a valuable
tool for understanding
cancer mechanism and identifying
biomarkers
so in this program we will work
on this exciting story sorry
in this program we will work on this
exciting project that i wanted to show
you
[Music]
so
so this in this project we will use
translational research and biomarker
discovery
where we will be looking at cancer
subtype characterization
associating technical skill sets that we
learn
that how to process the data eliminate
technical issues
and use machine learning tools to
extract meaningful insights from
complex molecular data sets so another
project
that will be a part of this entire
training so this project was inspired by
demian at all so modeling precision
treatment for breast cancer
so which is an this is an analysis of
over 70 different
best uh cancer cell lines and over 90
different
therapeutic agents so this project
includes
uh include snp data so microarray data
on type of microarray data
rna seq data so the whole transcriptome
data exium data
and also you know white methylation data
which is the epigenetic data
so you already we discussed about the
tcga project and another set of
specialization
are the infectious disease related
projects
so the application of transcriptomic
data is
actually providing private information
in infectious disease research
so for example host transcriptomics in
tb and other diseases is a powerful
approach
for discovery of immune signatures so
transcript
for example if you take translator
analysis of
human samples that can provide insights
into
which genes are expressed in a sample
tissue and by comparing such
transcriptomic profiles
in samples from subjects with a disease
versus a subject without a disease
so it is possible to identify genes that
differs in their expression between the
groups
and thus it provides us a picture of a
disease signature
right so as uh and one of the major
advantages
of learning from the examples that i
showed you and then
hands-on exercises so you can quickly
adapt
adopt and work on your own independent
project
so these interesting research projects
are proposed by our previous
participants from different programs by
utilizing the public repositories
and in this program we will learn how to
navigate through different
specialized repositories like ncbi
uniprot
ccga and several other databases
so we have been collaboratively working
with several universities
and reaching out to others to help
implement data-driven
project-based learning that enables
students at a young age
to ask significant biological questions
and
and also to faculty to leverage their
knack of research
so we have been working on several
bioinformatics projects with
these faculties so our collaborators
are effectively utilizing this
technology not only for education and
training
but also to develop collaborative
training programs and funding proposals
to support student research projects so
dr harshita here
specializes in botany and wants to
contribute to agricultural research
using bioinformatics tool
bioinformatics tools investigating the
genetic data from
tomato another example here
is from a student so many proposals from
group of students are really
like have been really very exciting for
example a group
led by sarah here she wishes to find out
about specific molecular pathways that
are responsible
for this amazing stress adaptation
in uh tardigrades
such an another example of such study is
by
nab energy from ju who wants to study
the lipid biosynthetic pathways
in a plant uh called psychos
sorry i have a simple course so uh
the idea is to find out uh significantly
uh differentially expressed genes
responsible for
you know lipid production so that can
help in biotechnology
so the application varies from
agriculture biotechnology
infectious diseases uh cancers and many
of our
uh previous uh participants had this
this chance to work on this different
research
projects and present this uh
analysis in reputed conferences and
workshops and publish online
so that's about the projects
and the research that we are being uh
that we have been doing and contributing
to
and to tell you more i would like to
invite biepsha
um about the program so over to you
okay thank you so much
i will be taking everyone through
the registration process and as i'm
going forward
i see that there are some questions
in the chat whether you receive a
webinar certificate for this one
uh we do not give out a certificate for
this particular webinar
but all of our programs and a few of the
free resources that
i will be introducing you to today will
have certificates of their own which you
can take
after this program is over so to join
the upcoming transcriptomics program
this is the link we will also email you
all this
link via email if you're already
registered and joining us
so if you go to this website you will be
able to see
uh details about this program okay needy
has a question how frequently these
programs are designed so typically these
different multi-omics programs
are repeated once or twice a year
so as i mentioned before the
transcriptomics program
is being repeated for the third time
this year
and of course in the next upcoming year
we will have
the program again um though right now we
do not have any dates for it yet
but we continue to repeat these programs
because
uh these are very basic stepping uh
stone
kind of introduction for students
yes uh mansi all of it is related to
bioinformatics everything that you see
here
these are all related to bioinformatics
topics so we
this program specifically today is
related to transcriptomics rna-seq
analysis
and we also have programs related to
metagenomics or microbiome
data analysis we have programs on
infectious diseases so
there are different programs that we do
all throughout the year
uh yeah sure so we will reach out to you
regarding uh
the presentation or the video of this
program
later on via email now uh just to show
you how you all can register again
as i was pointing out yes i will come to
that uh
in a moment for the pricing in inr
so as you see in this page you will be
able to get
uh introduced to this program
and you can see the entire syllabus so
we are starting the program
next wednesday
uh december 9th and the program
will have live sessions until december
23rd the program does not
end on december 23rd these are the
duration of the different online classes
or online sessions
like today and after december 23rd you
will have about
two to three weeks until january 9th
to work together to complete all of the
different courses that are there go
through the different resources
as well as if you want to work on your
own individual project
now i would quickly want to go ahead and
address some of the questions
that are there in the chat and then move
forward from here
so to know about this program if you
click on get started
we offer three different levels
if you are a beginner or if you are
somebody who is just starting for
the first time and you are getting
introduced to bioinformatics yes
if you have not studied bioinformatics
you can still
go ahead and join the program and the
reason is because
we will be having classes like this
where you will be able to interact with
the mentors you met
today and and who spoke to you
previously
and they will answer those questions for
you we have courses
i will give you an example of those
courses where you will be able to
go through these different materials
which are very very
basic and takes you right from a very
introductory level
to a more advanced level so yes you
would be able to
do that but of course it also depends
that you are able to make
time for it and give time to it so that
is there
so this is the beginner session so if
you are just joining the program
for the first time then all you need to
do
is you can sign up for this so 150 usd
uh is in inr
exactly is equal to okay i would have to
check this out because i'm not really
sure
but let me just pull it up for
you okay so it comes down to around 11
000 ir and we will be getting back via
email so you
if you have any other exact questions
like you know how
much these uh pricing comes to in your
value you can just let us know via email
and i will be responding
because it's not possible to tell to
everybody because all of you are joining
from different
countries around the world so this is
the standard pricing
and here are the payment options so you
can check out via here
and moving on so what do you do once you
are signed up so how do you
get access to these different resources
so the first resource that
every person who joins this program has
access to
is an organization page so
the organization page is like what you
can call a classroom
every member of this program will be
part of
this organization page and you can only
get access to this page once you're
registered for the program
so when you come down you'll be able to
see all the different
events for the program so see we are
starting on 9th
december with the overview of the
program then we
go with 11 december with processing of
gene expression data
we are going into more details then
we are exploring gene expression tables
and learning about statistical analysis
on 14th december
and so on and so forth so you see there
are uh
sessions dedicated to learning about
machine learning
and single cell transcriptomics as zelia
was talking about
earlier so you will be able to go
through all of these
things right here in this one page which
you will have access to so that you can
access all of your resources right from
there
so one of the resources that you see
here is a forum so i'll just give you an
overview of what a forum looks like
so basically the forum will have several
different topics so this is an example
of an old forum
that i wanted to just show you so each
of you will be able to post
questions get those questions answered
right here in the forum
in case you are missing a session or if
you have um
questions that you don't get answered or
you're going through the courses and you
have these
doubts and we are not meeting at that
point of time you can just post on the
forum and
one of our team members would be able to
get back to you so we also
have another question here do we have to
do the program live
yes so as i showed these scheduled
classes
are going to be live sessions but
they're also going to be recorded like
we are recording it today
so in case you are not able to make
yourself available for the scheduled
classes you can also
take this entire course asynchronously
wherein
we will be emailing you the video
recording of the sessions
that you can see and along with it you
will also be able to go through the
different courses
that are available so there are
different courses which elie also showed
you we have transcriptomics one to
transcriptomics four
and there are also other several
different courses that you can take
so you will also be able to take these
courses asynchronously
as well and if you have any questions
we also have the option for one-on-one
mentor sessions where if you have a lot
of questions and you have
progress really well and you have a
certain in-depth questions or
some problems with your assignment you
can actually email us and request for
that session as well so that is also
available
in case you want to go forward with it
and now i want to show you
uh what your profile will look like so
this is an example from a participant
who recently
completed our last transcriptomics
program which we had in september so as
you see tapestry here
she has completed the program she has
over 14
810 points and the interesting part
about
these points is the fact that these
points are collected each time
you do a course any of the courses that
you do here
will earn you around 500 points and elia
also showed you the server t-band for
platform
so the more pipelines you run on the
server t by info platform
you will be getting points for them also
for the platform where we teach about r
and python the codomix logic
uh which is right this one you will also
get points for this so everything is
associated with your profile
so you are not only able to do the
program but you can actually see your
progress right from
day one uh to the last day of the
program
and if i can just show you for tapestry
you can see the number of courses she
has completed during that time period
the number of pipelines she has run
right here
so this is exactly how you can also
track your own progress
and we can also see whether you are able
to progress further so if there is any
problem you can actually get back to us
and we can
communicate with you and help you sort
that out
so that is the support that we provide
for all of our programs whether you're
joining it
in the next week or in the next year
and besides these resources as of course
you will have
educational access to this platform
which is our data analysis platform and
we will actually go on step by step
through these different logic of
analysis like what is the utility of
these different pipelines
and there are different assignments as
well within the courses which will
help you to look at the different data
sets and work with these different types
of multi-omics
logic and analysis and of course
as i mentioned you will also have access
to the code omits logic playground as
well for learning
rn python as elia has shown you before
so do you all have any other questions
that i can help
answer if you have any questions please
let me know
i can take a moment to answer them
if you do not have any questions uh
right
now okay yes so andrea has another
question
uh do we can you buy courses separately
or is it
per month only so for this program you
do not have to buy
the courses separately like all of these
resources
will come under whatever you are paying
for the program right here
which is a 150 dollars which comes with
both the courses resources
also free access to all the premium
courses which are available
on the codomex logic and the mentor
support
as well as the project if you are
attempting to do the project
then also it covers it all but if you
are interested in exploring or taking up
a course
on its own i can send you the link for
that
after the session so if you can leave
your email in the chat box then i will
be able to reach out to you
and we can you can also take up each of
the single courses but
um only that those courses would be self
study ones or asynchronous courses
and it does not come with mentor support
but definitely the courses are very very
detailed so you would be able to go
through them yourself
do we have any other questions and thank
you so much
saunder for sharing this
uh the project is a publishable project
okay so i will show you some project
examples that we have
from our previous participants
who were part of the program
so to publish a project as you know
uh takes a long time and this program is
only a one month program
but if you are interested only in
working on an rmac
project or any other project for that
matter we also have a
research fellowship program that you can
actually take a look at so that
research fellowship is offered for
either three months
or six months and
it will be helpful for you if you are
thinking of doing a project
in the long run okay i hope andrea that
answers your question
and if you need more information i can
email you that as well
for pratik do we need to know the
computer languages for these courses uh
so no predict you do not need to know
any computer languages for any of these
courses
because everything is built for you
writer in the cloud so it does not
require you
to know the programming languages if you
already know
then that is really really great but in
case you do not do
this no reason that you have to start
learning it before the program or
something you can actually take these
courses without
having any prior knowledge of car or
python
or even about algorithms in bifo matrix
which you will see
in the different pipelines that are
shown out here so
this is why the platform is a very very
student friendly
and great for beginners to start with
who are not very familiar with the more
advanced
ways of biofuel matrix analysis
okay
all right i will send you the info
andrea thank you and thank you everybody
for sharing your email ids
so if you all have any questions
beyond the session that you would want
to inquire about
i'm available at marketing and find.bio
and you can also reach our team here
marketing at pine.bio for these
questions
if you all have any other questions uh i
think
we have a few more minutes like two
three more minutes
before we will conclude today's session
uh you're welcome zorin
yes media i will be sharing the
information
via email
okay thank you everyone
oh okay the timing for the live sessions
so they will be at okay we have to
change this it will be at
9 00 a.m cst 9 a.m cst
um is going to be the time so if you are
in
india it is going to be at 8 30 p.m in
the evening
and 9 a.m cst in the morning for the
u.s session and if you are living in any
other countries outside of these two
time zones
you can convert 9am cst to your local
time
so that you will be able to see that
time and i can also email you if you
have any more doubts regarding this
i hope that everybody enjoyed today's
session thank you again for joining us
today
so we will be seeing you all again very
soon
and hope you can join us in the upcoming
session starting from next week